Now we are going to talk about how
actually Access Control is implemented
in real operating systems.
We actually going to talk
about Unix-like systems, but
there is similar things done
in other operating systems.
Let's focus on Unix-like systems.
And so we have to think about users,
resources, access permissions and
things like that for
us to understand how access
controlled is handled by this system.
So in Unix, actually every resource for
which access needs to be
controlled looks like a file.
So in your next like system we
also know that users have UID.
Unique identifiers for
the users that we have in the system.
Users can also be groups and certain
users could be members of a group.
There is a special group.
Every user in system
that's the world group.
And we look at access control for
a file, we're going to say,
well, who is the owner?
What kind of access does the owner have?
Is there some group that
access to this file?
What kind of access that is,
and what about everybody, people who
are not owner or members of this group?
Since resources of files,
they can be read, written or
executed, these
are the three access rights.
So at this point, we know, we think
about your access control matrix
instruction, rows would
correspond to each UID and
each group ID that we have, GID and
a special group world that we have.
Column is going to correspond to each
file that we have in the system and
if you look at an entry in
the access control matrix
it's going to be a subset
of read write execute.
Unix system, the original ACL
implementation was actually,
had a compact fixed size implementation.
Remember, ACLs are ACEs,
so that's for each user,
so the owner is one of the users,
then the group would be the next one,
and then everybody is this special
world group that we are talking about.
So actually had only three
maximum of three ACEs.
Actually had three possible ACEs and ACL
it wasn't implemented as a link list.
It wasn't implemented.
It was implemented as a bit mask.
In particular, we need nine bits.
So the nine bits encoded read,
write, execute for owner.
Let's say the bit is on for
read for a given write,
then the user has that write.
So the user can read it.
This is how the compact
fixed sized representation,
perhaps in those days seven
memory was important, so
they implemented ACLs using
this essentially nine bits.
Little bit more complicated,
but that's the main idea.
A few things,
few extra bits we'll talk about.
Now this does have its limitations,
for example, you can only have three
subjects or principle whom access
can be either just the owner or
just one group or everybody.
If we had 10 different users,
you want to get information to six or
three or whatever it is,
we can't have an arbitrary size
access control list with this
representation we had here.
So operating systems actually now
provide implementations of full ACLs,
and it's available in many operating
systems, Linux, MacOS, BSD, and so on.